hello have we
started okay we've started great thanks
for coming to this talk I noticed there
were some great talks happening in the
other sessions right now um da is EV
infrastructure super exciting so had to
be here and not in there so today in
here I'll be talking about architecture
modernization uh before I get into the
talk I guess just explain a few things
about myself this talk is going to be
about my perspective of modernization
you might have some different opinions
and different
experiences so basically I've done this
as a full-time employee last 5 years
I've been a consultant so Consultants
perspective here but not one of those
big Consultants who comes in with a
framework and tells you exactly what to
do and all that stuff um working in a
small group of people um I wrote a book
about architecture modernization so I'm
kind of bored
of talking about it to myself in the
mirror it's actually great now I've
actually got some ideas I can come and
talk to other people about and uh I'm
also the co-organizer of DDD London
Meetup uh trying to do meetups every
month trying to give people a chance to
get together in person and connect so if
you're in London please drop by if you
want to give a talk happy to host you um
if you've never done a talk before happy
to have people doing their first time
talks so yeah open invitation let's get
into the talk then so if you're a
company why would you consider
architecture modernization you're a
successful company um why would you
spend some time messing around with old
Legacy systems when you can build new
features is it just developers who want
to play with the latest tech or is there
any actual reason for modernization
think about think about a big company
you know we laugh at big companies
sometimes um established companies not
necessarily big some serious advantages
to being a big company you've got market
share you're making money you've got
customers who know your brand there's
loyalty to your brand people use your
products they come accustomed to using
your products even if you're competitors
build a better product because people
know you there's a there's a switching
cost there a mental one and also on a
technical level migrating all of their
data and their users from all of your
products to other products there's a lot
of effort involved in a big company
doing that for your whole all of your
employees it's a lot of effort so
because you got there first people might
stick with your product even if a
competitor has a product that's better
than
yours you've also got big budgets you
know you can pay the top salar these
startups don't have as much money so
they have to find other ways to entice
people to come and work for them but as
we all know being successful has a
number of drawbacks in in this kind of
context we think about Legacy software
Legacy
systems get stuck in the mud impossible
to make changes slows companies down but
we also have problems on an
organizational side bureaucracy red tape
I'd like to add a new library to my
project that helped to do something like
logging or something else in a much
simpler way well you need to get
Securities approval and they said
already said no you're going to have to
use some library from 5 years ago that's
been approved and they're not willing to
approve anymore so you know all these
rules and red tape bureaucracy builds up
over time and being a successful company
all these all these things trying to
pull you back plus you get stuck on Old
Technologies it's not possible to just
take an old system click your fingers
and have it running on the latest
Frameworks in the latest Cloud
infrastructure
so it gets difficult to change that over
time and so because of all of these
reasons smaller companies younger
companies they have an advantage now
they can use the latest tech they don't
have Legacy holding them back they don't
have all of this bureaucracy that's
built up so being a big company has some
advantages but obviously many
disadvantages and a company I could talk
about some bad examples here companies
that you know didn't take the warning
signs but that's boring a good example
is Open Table my friend Orlando Perry
going back about 10 years ago now he he
worked there I know some other people
who worked there as well
basically big monolithic code base
hadn't been particularly welld designed
it's got 100 Engineers all working in
there deploying it once a month lots of
merge conflicts lots of lots of uh
friction just uh Implement
features what open table recognized both
on a technical level and a product level
is that they could actually see their
competitors entering the industry moving
quickly adding new
features and this company realized if we
don't modernize we're probably going to
fall behind the competition so they
invested in
modernization round about a year later
and they hired a lot of smart people to
help with this it's not just you know
it's not an easy thing to do this um and
you know bigger company compes it might
take much longer than one year um but
within about a year later Open Table had
a bunch of independent teams all deploy
production multiple times per day and
they were ahead of the competition in
their abilities to move at
speed sorry about
that something else that's important why
companies need to modernize it's not
always a case of we make we took loads
of shortcuts we built up loads of
technical debt you know we we did this
to ourselves even if you make good
decisions even if every architectural
decision you make is
perfect something might change in the
future and suddenly a decision you made
back then based on things that made
sense then suddenly is not optimal
anymore so modernization is hard to
avoid even if you make good decisions
good example here is Vinted as orello
explained
they were struggling to implement new
features finding it very difficult one
of the key reasons was they built a
system around the idea of being active
in one vertical women's clothing I know
nothing about women's clothing or any
clothing it's not my topic but the point
is quite obvious here they designed a
system every every code
concept hope that's not for me um
basically the whole system had been
designed around women's clothing
obviously as the company became
successful company wants to grow into
other verticals probably other things I
know nothing about and so now they're
trying to build these features onto a
code base that's got abstractions that
were not anticipating this kind of
evolution so that's the kind of
challenges we Face even if you make good
decisions at some point modernization is
often inevitable not
always um you know so when I think about
modernization what I think about and in
my experience is it's established
companies who are starting to feel the
pain of the Legacy they've built up
they're starting to feel some
competition in their market and they
want to convert these old architecture
and their old ways of working into
something more modern that allows them
to compete with these fast moving
companies effectively they want the Best
of Both Worlds be a successful company
well-known brand market share big
budgets but able to innovate at speed as
well so in this talk today I'm going to
cover this topic from three different
angles the first one is about flow about
how quickly we can get work done in our
company as you've seen in these examples
when people modernize their architecture
it's usually because work isn't getting
done fast enough so talk about that then
I'll quickly touch on five different
tools which I think are essential in an
architecture modernization Journey you
might disagree that's good I'm open to
disagreement and then finally last part
of today's talk I'm going to touch on
the getting started and keeping a
modernization journey moving that's
where a lot of modernization
Journeys fall apart before they've got
started or just after they've got
started everyone's got great ideas
everyone's Keen to modernize but you
know someone doesn't make a decision or
some other work comes in and then
modernization gets ped to the side and
you you back where you were before have
haven't really made any progress so I'll
show a couple of techniques which I
think are really effective in that area
but no silver bullets here I'm not
saying if you do all the stuff in this
talk it will guarantee success I think
it will increase your chances so let's
talk about
flow and before talking about that
specifically um I want to address the
point that a lot of these conversations
around modernization talk about
technology
change using some moving from mobal to
something more modern moving from on
premises to the cloud moving from VMS to
something more serverless or container
based while that's
important if you only focus on those
things you won't get the benefits of
modernization the full benefits because
think about your system now you've got
an evented example touched on this your
system doesn't have the optimal design
changing the technology won't fix all of
the coupling and the bad design and the
shortcuts in your system so technology
is one part
but modernization needs a broader scope
than that so if companies are investing
in modernization because flows important
in a modern context then we need to we
need to have this as the building blocks
of our architecture and that's basically
what value streams are a value stream is
sequence of activities that a team will
go through or multiple teams or some
group of people to create some new kind
of value you all probably work in teams
you all probably part of one or more
value streams
what can we build let's have an idea
let's find some ideas let's prioritize
stuff let's define some
requirements let's implement it let's
test it let's deploy it and then in a
modern context fast flow means doing
that all all in short increments
multiple times per day so deploying
small chunks every day so if we think
about value streams we're on the right
track we're keeping flow in mind we're
not being driven by Tech we're being
driven by flow what's important to the
business but the problem is just
thinking about value streams isn't
enough even if we design value streams
and we have software which is aligned to
these value streams we still have to
worry about change coupling change
coupling is basically on a business
level or product level we want to
implement some new
feature the problem is we need multiple
teams each to implement some part of
this so now this change cing means we've
got team coordination teams have to
spend some time figuring out which team
will build which piece how will we
design the interfaces between our
different parts oh this team's got other
work in their backlog so they're not
fully focused on this these teams don't
agree about the best way to implement it
so all this having to coordinate teams
it takes much more effort than one team
implementing a feature I I will say that
we can't get avoid all change coupling
but the goal is is let's identify as
much as we can that can be removed and
and designed for that so I think what we
need to focus on our independent value
streams independent as I was just
touching on doesn't mean isolated there
will be some coupling but if we follow
these four guiding principles or these
four characteristics I think we can get
much closer to highly independent value
streams so the first one is about being
domain aligned general idea here is if
we want Loosely coupled software and we
want to avoid change coupling between
teams then we need to start by
identifying which parts of our business
can evolve independently when we get a
new requirement what are the parts of
the business involved in that in DDD we
call those subdomains we organize our
business into domains and subdomains so
that's the first step the second part is
then thinking about the outcomes what
are the business outcomes that this
value stream is contributing to out
comes are important for a few different
reasons I guess the first one is we want
to understand how important is this
value stream with respect to our overall
architecture our overall portfolio
what's good enough here what level of
flow is good enough here what level of
modernization is going to be good enough
here outcomes are also important because
it feeds into the next point about teams
being able to make decisions and make
changes if teams have clear business
outcomes like engagement for you
improving processing time which you'll
get to shortly then teams can make
decisions in the value stream without
having a dependency outside the value
stream the alternative approach is a
feature
Factory have these product people over
here who Define the requirements a nice
product requirements document gets
handed over to the
team team builds what they think they've
been asked to build but actually it's
not what they've been asked to build so
we've got you know some back and forth
some disagreement team's guessing teams
not understanding the domain so the
outcomes can help the team make those
decisions the team can decide what
they're going to build they can own more
decisions in that value
stream and then finally we've got the
software bit if a team is able to
actually have ideas choose what to build
then the final bit is actually can they
change a code implement it in software
and deploy that software so independent
here means a team is able to implement a
feature
and deploy that feature on their own
without needing any help or support from
other
teams so company that did this another
one of my friends I've got a lot of I've
got a friends who make good choices in
their careers so this is a company
called Ice uh effectively it's in the
domain of royalty calculations uh it's
quite a very complex domain my friend
Casper works here so when they set out
on their modernization Journey this is
one area of their business as you can
see
initially they' got a system that's been
designed in a very technical Focus as
you can see import export system is that
part of the business is that part of the
domain or is that talking about the
technical mechanics of how the software
works and not really the intention
behind it system had a lot of coupling
teams were quite big um teams had to
know about lots of different moving
parts of the system so cognitive load
was high couldn't deploy very often so
you know not not getting the benefits
they wanted not moving as quickly as
they wanted and so Casper and his
colleagues um took an approach where
they started identifying their domains
and subdomains as you can see here usage
in gesture matching Roy
calculation they identified outcomes
that they wanted to achieve on a
business level as you can see on the
right hand side they were able to reduce
their ingestion processing Times by 80%
and uh matching process improved 5X so
they had clear business outcomes and
teams were able to work closely with
domain experts learn the domain they're
working in make decisions on a product
level and they were able to deploy
changes independently each team was
deploying um on a very regular
basis one other thing I want to quickly
talk about is this idea of just taking
the old system and rewriting it in new
tech it's concept of beat your
parity this is also problematic if you
do this you're going to spend a lot of
time and a lot of money modernizing
things that just don't need to be
modernized you don't just take an old
system and rewrite it you might do this
with some parts of the system but as an
overall Global strategy I don't think
I've ever seen this work well and
usually what happens is it takes so long
you never get to finish because people
aren't seeing the value coming out of it
not sure how accurate this survey is but
I I think it gets the idea across nicely
right pendo did a survey and they found
that
80% of product features are rarely or
never used so if we take that as a
guideline if you modernize an old system
and just rewrite it maintaining exact
feature parity probably going to spend
80% of your time doing stuff that isn't
needed so what I like to think about is
a full stack modernization and I'm not
just talking about the front end and
backend framework
I'm talking the full stack in terms of
your product and the capabilities it
represents so at the bottom layer you've
got the domain itself the business
domain you're working in can you improve
the domain can you introduce new
capabilities can you simplify existing
operational processes then you have the
model of your domain this is how you
describe your domain the language you
use the concepts you use to talk about
your domain by creating a richer domain
model you can have more effective
Communications and this conceptual
domain model can then be implemented in
code which is going to improve the
design of your software obviously when
we talk about code we can also improve
the on the tech side of things and then
at the top of the stack we've got the
user interface a lot of effort can be
done here to improve the user experience
if you take an old system and rebuild it
and keep the same
ux that is just a massive missed
opportunity again it might be it might
be sensible in some cases but if you're
going to modernize at least take the
effort to make some improvements for the
ux example here from my career I worked
for the UK government in 2016 and we
were modernizing the full stack of
business property taxes so some of the
business policies well not business
government policies around how tax is
calculated and how people pay it and
what they're obliged to pay they existed
for decades it was actually the law
these were government policies enshrined
in laww and we were modernizing those we
were thinking like what would make sense
here we had domain experts and
developers thinking what makes sense on
a logical level and what can we do in
software um spent a lot of time on the
domain talking about where the
boundaries are how we talk about the
domain trying to create this shared
language um massively modernize the
software um it's a very old systems got
them running on Java on the jvm on a
Docker based platform uh moving to more
domain driven architecture as well and
on a ux level a lot of effort went into
the ux we had user researchers in each
team going out every Sprint talking to
real users developers would go as well
to the research lab so in this in this
particular context it made sense to put
all of that effort in I'm not saying you
would do this everywhere what I'm saying
is think about the full stack and at
least be aware of what you could
modernize it's not just the Technologies
there's a lot to think about
here so if you agree or like or have
that perspective on what modernization
is then I think there are some tools
that you'll find very useful for that
kind of modernization journey and the
first one is
listening what I mean by listening is
before you start talking about tech
going around talking to people in your
company and just trying to understand
what are the biggest problems you're
facing what are your I for the next 3 to
5 years what have you given up asking
for what would you love to do what is
keeping you up at night very often when
modernization starts out talking about
cloud and the latest tech and the
narrative gets shaped from there people
start equating it with a mod a
technology thing and so other
stakeholders don't feel connected with
this approach you're doing it the other
way around just talking to people it's
actually I found it really difficult to
do that actually um but I as a
consultant I got to do this a lot of
times and I kind of picked up some
techniques um I'm not very good at small
talk something else I found really
important about this though is if you
start talking to
people just listening to what they have
to say and not pushing Solutions you
start to build
relationships so when it comes to making
a decision putting a proposal together
asking can we modernize this those
people are much more likely to feel like
oh I've got a relationship with that
person I'll support that I'll give them
some buying they've listened to me that
the proposal takes into account my
thoughts much more likely to get
buying beginner mistake is obviously
coming in too early with leading
questions and solutions someone's got a
problem about crms you come in and say
oh so Salesforce will fix all your
problems that's you want to keep away
from that at the start just being
comfortable not talking about Solutions
just seeing where the conversation goes
and uh gently moving things in in
different directions just trying to
tease out what's important to them
different time
Horizons and what I've what I've noticed
probably over the last couple of years
mostly I would say the challenge I face
mostly um
is you know modernization can get stuck
because you can't make decisions there's
a lot of ideas how do you choose the
right idea when you don't have clear
business OB persectives things can get
stuck people developers might say well
we could modernize that old part of the
system it's going to take 6 months or
longer is it worth it we don't know
because we don't have clear business
priorities so a listening talk can help
get clarity on those business priorities
which you can then use to justify your
modernization decisions something else
that's very useful is impact mapping
it's a bit more structured so if you're
not good at um conversations like I
wasn't this can give you a bit more of a
structure to work with so you start with
the business objectives in this example
I was talking to a chief marketing
officer he explained to me over the next
couple of years we have to put 20 we
have to increase our Revenue by 20
million it's important for the investors
it's important to maintain our growth
and then he started explaining to me how
he thinks the company can achieve that
you'll talk to different stakeholders
and they'll give you different things
it's not like there's one listed
priorities here it's a messy world but
at least you know what you could be
working on and what some people feel is
important is example here Enterprise
users improving some of the processes um
accuracy rates and he talked about some
deliverables that he thought could be
useful in achieving that so now when we
think about architecture modernization
are we making decisions that contribute
to this if we are we're probably going
to get buying and support we're probably
modernizing for the right reasons
next tool is wly mapping so wly mapping
you start by creating value chains not
value streams different things a value
chain starts with your users and their
user needs what have we got in this
example um a customer wants to enjoy
some food without cooking they want some
take away food so that's your user
that's your need you can then start
thinking about what are your
Architectural Components what are the
different parts of your
system that fit to together to enable
these business and customer outcomes to
be achieved this example we've got uh
the mobile app the menu service ordering
service payment service I quite like
microservices I know it's not very
popular right now but I've had some fun
over the years with them so then you've
built your value chain not value stream
value chain I often make that mistake
myself so didn't this time so you you've
mounted out your value chain what you
then do is move each component to a
stage of E Evolution Genesis custom
product or
commodity on the left You' got Genesis
these are Concepts on a business level
that are new and unproven there's High
future potential but that potential
hasn't been realized yet as you move
across ideas become more established in
customer product an idea has been proven
and there's an opportunity for your
business to differentiate on that
feature it's a place where um
competition's happening in your industry
as you get to commodity we're now
reaching the table Stakes the old
features every company has it customers
just expect it to work in a certain way
there's no chance of differentiation
here why is this important because now
you can make very sensible strategically
aligned modernization decisions you know
that towards the left because there's a
high potential for different
differentiation you really want to have
fast flow in those value streams towards
the right hand side in commodity there's
not much chance of differentiation on a
feature level so here it's all about
reducing costs how can we make the cost
of running that old Legacy system
cheaper could we use an off the-shelf
tool those are the typical kind of
conversations happening in that space
obviously I'm simplifying a bit here but
hopefully you get the idea but we're not
finished yet when you use a wly map to
make modernization decisions you don't
make decisions based on the current
position of a
component what you need to do is
anticipate how is that component going
to evolve over the
next time frame and that time frame is
something you need to think about one
year two year three year 5 years what's
happening in your industry are there a
bunch of companies all trying to build
this thing and they going to catch up
with you or is it something that's going
to evolve slowly
you know you might want to think about
where's where are large language models
on here right now would you think that's
something that's going to evolve slowly
or is it going to become a commodity
very quickly think we can see some
different aspects there so in this
example we've got a component it's going
to evolve from Custom to almost
commodity in one year so even though
it's um in custom
now we might originally think oh it's
important to have differentiation here
we can modern this to a high level and
enable fast flow but actually in one
year it will be almost a commodity and
it will be much less important then so
we have a very shortterm Focus here
maybe a modernization that enables
long-term fast flow probably Overkill in
this
area then we get to the next tool and my
next drink
break I reckon I can get to the end from
here without having any more
drinks quite Ambi ious so tool number
four event storming event storming comes
in different flavors big picture is
about mapping out your business as is
you get a bunch of stakeholders
developers testers product people QA
people managers customer support anyone
who knows anything about the part of
your business you want to model get them
in a room you map out your domain using
the main events on a wall you know a
room like this would be awesome for
event storming you could map out a map
massive part of your business on a wall
like that once you've done this you've
now got a a very granular view of your
business you can zoom in and zoom out as
needed and you can start to really get
into the details of what problems are
different people facing where are the
challenges here if we're going to
modernize these processes what should
the new version look like what's wrong
with the current version that we
wouldn't want to keep in the new world
then you've got process modeling event
storming that is your New World before
you start building building the new
system you can use process modeling to
redesign your domain your user Journeys
your workflows and think about how would
it work ideally in an Ideal World what
will this process look like can we
simplify it can we add new features can
we automate manual steps all that kind
of stuff and then this gives you a
template for what the new version will
look like when you start to implement
the modernized
version event storming is also a great
tool for actually designing your
architecture once you've mapped out a
business you can start to organize parts
of the event storm into domains and
subdomains which are obviously the
starting points for your value streams
very useful for
that the fifth and final tool is the
modernization strategy selector maybe
the Tool's not so important here but the
idea is important to keep in mind in
your modernization journey you need some
way of
assessing what level of effort are we
going to put into each part of our
system and there's a couple of different
axes to think about here the first one
is obviously the tech side the platform
side are we going to lift and shift an
old code base from on Prem to the cloud
we'll change the infrastructure but
we'll leave all of the other Tech as
is um or you're going to completely
change the whole teex stack and then the
other aspect of this is the
functionality side are you going to add
new features to the code base are you
going to simplify the old code base are
you going to redesign the domain model
so two different axes to think about
there and the goal is always what's
going to be optimal what's the optimal
strategy here in each area of our
architecture it's not going to be a
global strategy we need to think
granularly what what's the optimal
investment in each area and again this
is an area
where some companies go a bit off track
taking Global approaches investing a lot
of effort where it's not
needed um as I talked about yeah
different different levels to think
about there um you can read more about
that later I'm not going to talk about
this tool but I think there's a six tool
that's really important I'm seeing a lot
more of this these days it's called code
scene it's a tool that can analyze your
architecture looks at your Version
Control history and it can visualize the
coupling in your system can also
visualize which parts of the system have
no owner what you've got knowledge gaps
in your company very useful
tool so to finish today I'm going to
explain how you can Kickstart and enable
your architecture modernization journey
and I'm not going to have a drink before
I finish so why is this important so
it's important because as a consultant I
see things that I I didn't realize were
happening so for example company will
say we we've started mapping out all of
our domains and subdomains it's taken
six months how long should it take um
that's a that's big design up front
right we don't want to do that we need
to be sensible here we need to do some
thinking up front but but we don't need
to apply these techniques I told you
across the whole system before you start
modernizing in fact I'm very ambitious
in the other direction I really
encourage companies try and deliver
something in 3 to six months because
once you start delivering you start
learning once you've actually delivered
some modernization people can see it's
real it's not just an idea anymore and
that builds people start to believe it's
going to work and you can say you're not
saying to people this modernization
could be a great idea please support us
you're saying look we've delivered
something it worked give us some more
money and we'll give you some more of
this good stuff so you know just
delivering you can still think about the
big picture whilst you're delivering but
you know just don't go too much in that
upfront design
phase some kind of tool can be useful
here here's a general kind of concept I
use you know what's the value of
modernizing something and what's the
effort of doing it um typically that
first slide Dev is going to be a
difficult choice between do we pick
something that's easy to
modernize where we can test out some
ideas or do we pick something that's a
bit more difficult but it's got a high
level of business value in
there I've got no I've got no single
answer here because I think it varies
I've seen both of these work and both of
these go wrong if you start with
something simple in the bottom left you
don't have so much pressure um you can
test out new tech and you can go your
own pace and try out things it's not a
problem if you fail or if you have to
change some decisions the problem is
people start asking questions why are
you spending six months modernizing that
part of the system that no one cares
about so people can start thinking that
modernization doesn't have value it's a
tech driven thing so if you're going
down that approach you know owning that
narrative is very important you need to
be clear that it's a first step in a
longer vision and while it's not a
valuable First Step it's Paving the path
more valuable steps later some companies
go towards the top right they pick
something big and valuable and
important that gets people excited
people are more likely to invest in
something if they're going to get
something back on a business level but
the problem is because you're just
starting out there's a lot of unknowns a
lot of things to experiment with and if
you say we're going to modernize this
part of the system and we're going to
deliver some new
functionality and you put a deadline on
that if you say three or six months you
know any number of issues could pop up
networking issues product issues
prioritization issues and suddenly this
doesn't get delivered on time because of
all these unknowns that are likely to
happen people get a bit frustrated um
and they think oh it's it's a waste of
effort
so yeah it's a tricky decision but I
think you know mapping out the options
and having those conversations and being
explicit is the way to go something else
I think is very useful our Kickstarter
workshops Kickstarter workshops are
basically 3 to 5 days in person and the
idea is to set yourself up for that
First Slice of modernization so
typically what the topics will look like
here are someone from the product
someone from the business side will talk
about the strategy you'll then do some
event storming you'll then clarify the
options and then towards the end of the
workshop you want to start defining a
short-term road map or a plan so that
when this Workshop is over you're going
to start modern izing the goal of this
Workshop isn't just to get together and
have some fun it's really get
modernization
moving make some decisions make a plan
and start
modernizing um as a as I mentioned here
I think this workshops are great because
they get people excited you know people
come together do some event storming I
often hear comments like oh we've never
done this before makes it feel more
real this example here was from a
company me myself myself and Eduardo Sil
worked with um bit earlier this year the
picture you can see is the end of day
one we had 60 people probably a bit too
much um that's a different conversation
uh here's Ed wo's group as you can see
they mapped out this endtoend process
and if you if you look closely you can
see that there are some yellow strips
going across the top and those are the
subdomains and and really when you get a
workshop like that you bring together
these different stakeholders who
normally work in different SI
you got the CEO there the COO there and
they're like wow this company's never
done anything like this before it can be
really motivating and exciting and
getting People Pumped out for your
modernization
journey but the workshop doesn't
guarantee anything and very often people
have good workshops but then they get
stuck so how do you go from this
exciting Workshop to Let's actually get
modernizing no silver bullets here but
one of the techniques we recommend is an
architecture modernizing ation enabling
team if you red teams apologies you'll
know that an enabling team is a team
that has a mission to help other teams
help them achieve goals help them to up
skill an enabling team isn't a team it's
not a centralized architecture team it's
not a team that makes decisions it's not
a team that does the architecture work
and hands it over to teams it's a team
that it's a team that works with other
teams to help them achieve those goals
and AMT can connect
CTO and developers maintaining that
vertical connection it can also look for
gaps falling between
teams so if you're thinking about
setting up an Amat you have to be very
careful here you don't want to put
people in this team who are architecture
experts but they're not good at coaching
and talking to other people it's a very
it's a very specific kind of skill
that's needed both expertise and being
able to work and support other people in
a in a coaching fashion and the final
Point as you can see here here is an AM
isn't supposed to exist forever they're
here to get things started help teams to
be self-sufficient and then they're gone
they find some other purpose in
life so that's basically it I do want a
drink but I'm not going to have one CU
we're almost at the end now so just
going to quickly
recap you know
modernization successful
companies there were pros and cons to
being successful right you've got these
advantages you've got succcess youve Got
a Brand
reputation sometimes that's enough to
keep you as the market leader but very
often a lot of the Legacy you've built
up over time becomes too much of a
disadvantage and it makes you vulnerable
so that's why companies modernize they
want to be a successful established
company but they know that they have to
innovate faster because their industry
is hotting
up then talked about how modernization
is more than Tech you know very often as
I talked about modernization starts with
a technology narrative and it's hard to
get that back to this is about moving
the business forward this is about
transforming the business capabilities
not just on the tech
side talked about the full stack I think
that full stack model is important to
keep in mind how much of that stack do
you want to modernize for each part of
your system then talked about the five
essential tools maybe you don't have to
use these exact tools you can find
similar tools but each of these tools
soles a very specific purpose and is a
is something that you have to be
thinking about when you're
modernizing and then finally we just
talked about not getting lost up front a
lot of companies get stuck before they
get started do too much upfront planning
and that's where having a focus of three
to six months a really ambitious focus
and Kickstarter workshops and amets can
help you if you're feeling some inertia
there so that is everything and I am
allowed to have a drink now thank
[Music]
you